[Music]
hallo YouTube just Louis and my friends
this is grunge in here welcome to the
thirty fourth episode of my chest straps
he's in this episode I'm going to show
you one of the nasty trap in the slough
defense where actually you can trap your
opponent's queen and win the game very
quickly in the tournament practice the
opening arises after the following order
d4 d5 c4 c6 and now Knight to c3 now the
typical slower mainline start with the
move Knight to f6 however I'm going to
propose at this point the trendy move D
capture c4 winning a vital pawn at this
point White has two popular choices
amongst them we are going to look at the
move III however if you open and indeed
continue it efore then more or less of a
response will be similar as happen in
the game and you can definitely check
out some model games in this line which
will give you a very good idea
how to play against the movie foe
okay III what he's trying to grab his
pawn back but black says knob sweetie
I'm not going to allow this and I will
play this greedy move B Phi hanging on
to my extra pawn again I want to stress
that if your opponent continued with a 4
then you can respond with b4 and these
positions are quite good for the black
cam as it is confirmed by online
database as per the many books videos
and specially old theory they all
condemned the smooth the simple reason
is White has this nasty sacrifice Knight
captures b5 and suddenly black position
is in a completely desert
obviously black has to take it otherwise
his spawn structure will be ruined ounce
OC captures B phase of his response but
after this I think you see what white is
up to yup
Queen to f3 attacking the rook in the
corner and black has nothing better than
playing the moon Knight to c6 giving
back the piece and in fact these
positions are somewhat better for the
white camp so the old Theory stops here
saying that white is having a pleasant
game but in the recent times with the
help of professional engine black is
finding a new resources and one of them
is absolutely marvelous which we are
about to see here black is going to
continue with this sneaky move twin to
c7 so now if white doesn't take the rook
in the corner then after Bishop to be
seven black emerged with a piece of so
obviously by force white has to take the
rook in the corner and after that yup
you guessed it Bishop to b7 attacking
the Queen Queen has only one square to
go Queen captures a7 and now black has
to be patience he cannot play Knight to
c6 as White Queen has to escape route so
first the obvious movies ePHI
controlling those two important squares
and now indeed Knight to c6 is obvious
threat which trapped down the white
sweetie
for example if white continued with any
casual moves such as Knight to f3 then
we have Knight to c6 and that Queen is a
corner so accordingly at this position
white has the only decent move available
and that is Bishop capture c4
idea is very obvious now black cannot
play Knight to c6 as Bishop to b5 help
to escape the Queen okay so obviously
black has to take this bishop and
already black obtained a good advantage
as if you look at the material black has
two minor piece against rook and a to
pawn which is always favors the black
camp but in fact black can go for more
if white doesn't continue accurately
from here onwards now as per the online
database Knight to f3 is one of the most
popular choice in this position however
that leads to a queen trappy line but
before we look at it the important point
I like to highlight that even white find
the only light move in this position
namely Queen check black can already get
a decent advantage with Knight to d7
however I personally like Bishop to c6
which is more spicier and very direct
black Bishop is attacking to spot so
white response his force
White has to take on c4 blocking down
that bishop but now comes this very
sneaky move Bishop to b4 check and after
this I think however white plays he got
bad positions he can't play King to
affirm as after Bishop captures g2 White
Queen does not belong to this world
hahaha so that's not even a possibility
you can't think about taking on before
the simple reason is after Bishop
captures g2 not only black regain the
rook in the corner but at the end of the
sequence black emerged with an extra
piece so that leads to the only reply
left namely Bishop to d2
this black has this nice forcing
sequence Bishop captures d2 King
captures d2 pawn takes d4 White has to
take back with the pawn and after that
the simplest move in the world Knight to
e7 and if you carefully look at this
position yes in terms of material White
has a rook and a3 pawn against two minor
piece but in terms of the most important
chest aspect King safety White has a big
time issue as his King is stuck in the
center after blacks initial reply castle
I think it is only black who is having a
lot of fun in this line so finally let's
check out what is wrong with the move
Knight f3 which is in fact highest Lee
played from this position well I'm
afraid it's a big time mistake and the
simple refutation goes with this very
nice move Knight b6 not only boxing this
poor white queen but controlling the
vital importance c4 square and now as
you can see I have highlighted by the
arrows very simple but effective plan of
campaign that is 97 Knight to c8 and
then completely trapping down the White
Queen the most amazing part is even
though white see that this is coming on
he can't able to stop it now to
illustrate my point I like to show you a
model game which has been just recently
played where a 2300 literally crossed a
two thousand plus rated opponent within
18 moves in the game white played night
captain Z Phi and after the move Knight
to e7 he replied with defy giving escape
to the White Queen well black is equally
smart as he continued with this obvious
move Knight to fi not allowing White
Queen to escape and now another threat
is looming Bishop to c5 and whities in a
big dilemma how to deal with this threat
well in the game he opted for nightcap
to c4
his idea is after the obvious black
response Bishop to c5 white wants to
play d6 counter attacking the black
queen well black response was spot-on
he avoided any nuisance by playing the
move Queen to CH asking white now what
is your next step to rescue your
important baby okay black plays Knight
to be six last cheapo on the board
d7 check but black safety negotiate
everything with Queen to c6 and after
the only check d7 he calmly played King
to d8 and now to his horror white find
out that not only his queen is lost but
in the process of saving the Queen he
lost yet another piece the game finished
very quickly before has been tried last
desperation but black keep it very
simple he captured the night on b6
grabbing yet another piece and if
allowed in the next turn black is going
to take the Queen and in fact came
however white revealed the plan behind
the movie for as he continued with beef
I counter attacking the black Queen and
if Queen has been exchanged
then white might survive this game well
guess what just one move and resigns and
I hope you did find this move
if you want more time you can pause the
video I'm showing right now Queen
captures b4 hi so everything has been
grabbed in this game and I think at this
point white realize that the move he was
intended is Queen captures b7 doesn't
walk as Black has this little check
which indeed grabbed his queen
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this wonderful trap in the Slav
defense
remember when you opponent continue with
this online theoretical move Knight
captures beef I don't forget to punish
him with C captures B fire Queen to f3
and this modern move Queen to c7 which
allow White Queen to grab rook in the
corner but after Bishop to b7 it is only
white who is fighting for either
survival of the game or losing the Queen
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and I
will meet you in my next episode very
soon bye and take care